i'll be crying i'll be crying
i don't think you get it i'll be bawling
okay okay okay
demon just got out of the camp i got my
bro whenever
love is just not in my plan ah studio
you're right in my yacht
i'm doing 10 in a week something
something something something ah
long as they in my teeth
[Laughter]
that's how we started these days zersky
why not um
you already know what to do with the
patreon it's moving and shaking if
you're not
on the party boat then you're bored if
you experience fomo in everyday life you
should be experiencing it in um
triumphs now it's true boatloads should
be ironic
true um so yeah three pound a day
three pound a month tempe a day running
my pee you know the drills
um guys if you like the video like the
video comment on the video
um subscribe and obviously audio
listeners
if you like the cool mellow tones of the
vocals that you're hearing
leave a nice review subscribe get those
notifications up
and um yeah man without further ado
fun fact of the day guys um did you know
that
um will smith first met jada pinkett on
set of freshman so better
she um auditioned to be one of wilson's
girlfriends
she didn't make the card didn't make the
cut mia long got it
gang me a long guy right choice for
starters right choice
nia long guy and um i think at this
point he was already married to
cherie i think her name is jurisan pico
and like he's his first wife his first
one yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know
whether he had trey or not at the time
trey smith is funny yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah that was a fun fact they
first met on on the set of freshmen
do you remember the episode of freshman
that's actually crazy and how did it
pattern from there
i don't i don't know the internet's
after that cool um but yeah did you know
do you remember the uh i'm assuming
you've watched all the freshmen of
course okay
do you remember two uh things firstly do
you remember
do you remember the episode where was
that there was that bunny boiler yeah
i think she was old no she wasn't older
she was lisa's friend
and she came through to the party and
she was down to smash him
down to smash him and she tried to move
to him
she um asked no no no she wasn't here
long's friend she wasn't the only friend
he bumped into her in like a in like the
cafe or something okay
and um she's one she's got strong jaw
okay she's actually a
popular actress back then mixed racing
oh like light skinned black girl
okay um strong draw and
she uh i think they were having like a
party
he moved to her or she moved to him okay
and then she was down
um this is why it was with mia this is
whilst you were with with uh
neo or lisa whatever you want to say i
think this is what happened i can't
remember
all the details he worked at the the
spot right the uni spot yes yes he went
there
yeah she must have moved to him she was
down down down
he was scared but he was down also she
got curly hair long curly hair or not
because i can't remember this woman
um she's not curly nah she didn't have
curly but
body's tight okay body high okay
tight okay and um she
and then she was moving to him and then
lisa walks in
and he's like this is lisa they're
hugging up on lisa this is lisa this is
my lisa this is yeah yeah
i'm in a relationship and she's like
cool all right then he's having a party
or lisa's having a party at the yard
and then she comes through and she's
trying it with my man
it brings trying it with my man and then
lisa's has there's no idea
yeah she's unaware she's unaware and
then um she's like oh
would you mind driving me home and he
says yeah drive driver home he's like no
no
no no i'm not driving at home well
obviously he can't say why uh
and she's like don't be a [ __ ] just
drive him drive her home don't be
horrible and she's like yeah driving me
home
she drives her home she traces it in the
apartment
she says she's got a strong jawline in
it yeah yeah yeah i know exactly the
face is in my head
she's a she was a well-known actress
back then back in those years yeah
exactly who was talking about yeah moves
to man on the sofa yeah yeah
and he has to like dash her i'm pretty
sure he dashes her
i remember oh what else has she been in
i know exactly who you're talking she's
been in a few things but i have no idea
what
i feel like she's been in like boomerang
i was not saying eddie murphy again
she's probably been
i was going to say boomerang yeah i know
exactly who you're talking about now
that i've gotten the face in my head i
remember
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh fam that one
i was thinking
you got you got strong morals
she was down it's hard out literally had
to pick her up and throw her
fam and that one always for somebody six
in my head the other one was sucks in my
head do you remember the one
um where man's dad bails on him when his
dad comes back into the picture they go
disneyland everything yes yes and then
he's supposed to go away with him yeah
and uncle feels against the whole team
yeah yeah yeah and then uncle phil
tries to stop him yeah going and then
man's like
you are now my father from that scene i
get tingles every time i see it
it's tough fam it's tough and did you
know
that i don't know most people know it's
another fun fact as well um
because he actually had real-life father
issues in his actual personal life
when he was crying on that scene he was
it wasn't me he wasn't meant to cry
really he wasn't meant to cry ah because
remember when um
he hugged um will hugged um what's his
name
uh phil uncle phillips i call him off
going down will hug uncle phil at the
end of that scene and that's where it
ended
he was crying in that scene he wasn't
meant to cry it wasn't part of the
script
but it's because he had he just had it
he had that there it was it was part of
him
oh it was part of him yeah i remembered
that as well
oh you were not my father you were not
my father fun
i was like obviously me and my dad are
cool but
i feel it i feel it
why don't he want me man i said why
don't he want me
ah uncle phil was just like come here
please it was tough
ah what an emotional scene it was an
emotional scene what's an emotional
scene he's a great actor
both of them are he will smith has done
well
will smith has done well did you see him
on that actors have you seen like the
round table actors thing that they do
sometimes
no there's a weird youtube channel um
i don't know if it's on tv as well but i
know it's on youtube it's like a weird
youtube channel where they get uh i
think it's called the round table but
i'm not sure i could be getting it
completely wrong yeah cause i get mixed
up with red table talks as well okay
um but they get actors yeah uh sometimes
they get directors
and it's just a whole round table they
just talk it's just like a podcast for
like
really high-profile actors okay um and
it was one of him and his motivations to
be an actor because obviously he was
into music and stuff
it was his motivations behind being an
actor and man said he
got this is big because someone bought
it resurfaced
i think it's from a couple years ago but
it resurfaced when obviously the jada
thing
came out it was talking about how he got
cheated on
um when he was younger okay and then he
said
i'm gonna be the world's just as like a
uh like a payback thing i'm gonna be
like literally the biggest actor on
planet earth
so i can make sure [ __ ] like this never
happens to me again
i can make sure [ __ ] like this never
happens i'm gonna be the biggest thing
on planet earth
so [ __ ] like this never happens to me
again
still did big will you know
big will smith willard smith
[Laughter]
willard no not my boy
if me and him were boys me and him could
never be best friends
and that happened and that happened here
yeah it would be uncle phil all over
again
hey why does she want me man
i was like come here fam you're too good
for her
look at you your will will smell
who doesn't know you everybody knows you
ah all the guys want to be you all the
girls want to be with you playboy come
on fresh friends
i am legends seven pounds
will smith has been about he's done he's
done it all movies with margot robbie
what are we talking about
independence day let me record margaret
uh
it's called uh still stuff yeah it's
called
it's called like snitch nah not snitch
what's it called that's a good movie
though i can't remember what it's called
but yeah it's that movie
hitch mr lover love a hitch
big wool smith you know big man ah
getting cheated on by little jada
washed up jada red table
only relevant because of you and her
picnic nah
not my boy oh to be fair she's she's
more relevant now because of him but um
obviously she will stay in tupac before
him
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying like
she was relevant
back in the 90s family in the 90s maybe
2000 yeah he was a little something so
if you weren't married to will you'd be
washed up yeah you wouldn't be living in
this yard
she wouldn't she did a couple movies
here there and everything yeah little
couple things
jamie foxx [ __ ] um what's it called
with jamie foxx yeah
jamie foxx tom cruise she was like the
third lead
in um what's that movie called i [ __ ]
hate how bad my brains were names
uh it's collateral is it called
collateral
tom cruise has great hair he's a hit
last yes yes yes yes yes yes yes jamie
foxx
yeah yeah yeah yeah completely forgot
she was in that movie yeah she wasn't
leave him she barely had any lies she
was in that
what the four other three other black
women um
[Music]
was that her queen latifah someone else
and someone else
oh that was time ago though oh it's not
the more
she's the one with tiffany haddish in it
she's not in that one no
no this um that's that's a recent movie
i think i know which movie you're
talking about i think that's
i think it happened that's reason right
that's more creative tiffany haddish i
think like taraji p maybe yeah they want
us in everything
and
it's not that movie i was talking about
it's an older movie how is it where
um they're like robbers or something and
they get everyone
i have to find it i'm sorry i'm sorry
because when i say you're like oh yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know i can't remember but i know
it's old um but anyway i keep talking
hmm
yeah man she's only rid of him because
i'm my man and i use
how are you so more relevant than her
and she got two two red table podcasts
and she wants to start sucking set it
off i've never seen that movie you've
never seen it
you've got fluff it's just it's it's
it's
constant with you i know it's because
they've got fresh hoodies
i know it's not your fault it's the
fresh merch straight out of the box
see jada queen latifah vivian fox viveka
fox rather yeah yeah yeah dead set off
absolutely
yeah man he's just mad as well because
everyone thinks he's the sloppy sop as
well now because mine's like a barling
man's got hose fab man's got hose he
just keeps them hush-hush
he knows how to play the game
that's the thing you could never be
willard smith fam you could never secure
will smith
on a night yeah and
by the end of it you know you're not
going to ruin this household
i don't know what kind of allure he has
yeah but you
you're never going to do a tingle of
will and initially think like i'mma
rinse this guy for every everything he's
got
i reckon one sit down with my man at the
end of it you're like what am i doing
what am i doing what am i doing i was
lucky to [ __ ] him in the first place
i don't need money 100 100 this is will
smith we're talking about this is will
smith
he keeps his [ __ ] locked down
as soon as he jumps on instagram he
became one of the biggest people on
instagram
bro he's the godfather of instagram he
patterned instagram so well man said the
rock's doing what
jumped on two two posts millions
millions of millions of millionaires and
i said hold that
wow he's a great guy he's he's done a
lot
he's done a lot for him he's done a lot
man said it all started because he got
cheated on
i want to be the biggest actor i want to
be the biggest actor i'm playing uh so
this never has to happen to me again
happened to a man again what is top dawn
but up until that point the x would have
been
vex cause the one that cheated on him
the first time
she would have been like oh this could
have been me i could have been living it
up how could i have my own red table
talks
this could have been me it could have
been me fam
ah it must be the same like beyonce's ex
as well do you remember he was like a
blip in her life
i don't know um i can't remember why
i've seen it it could have been in one
documentary i remember
um i don't know whether he cheated on
her but
he was they were dating or whatever and
then he just i think he must have
cheated on a sign happen
and obviously then she got with jay-z
and no one no one knows who he is
anymore do you know what i mean no one
else
no you're not one now family he's just
he's just a nobody now
yeah you're probably not nobody probably
yeah it's one of the ones that
is also gotta be like what kind of
mentality do you have to have that like
i could have been
the nobody that's with someone famous do
you know what i mean you're still not
gonna be anyone for yourself
that's tough yeah i could have been
beyonce's man that's tough but still
i'm no one i'm rich but through being
beyonce's man
he could have pat in his door's open
yeah open galore yeah
he would have to take his surname her
surname oh yeah
whatever knows whatever she all knows
you're not a man you're not a man you'd
have had to take us away from
how to of course you're not a man he's
got no choice it's uh it's long but um
anyway moving on yeah mom new topic i
haven't told you what it is have i i've
told you what it is i didn't tell you
anyone
yeah yeah fam so yeah i've got a new
segment for you man okay um
so this is always fun it's more it's so
we're going to move into a like a little
bit of a segment
with um conspiracy stroke
fan theories so i've got a few fan
theories about shows and stuff like that
talking about basically just just like
slightly accurate
theories that make you think ah that
could be that could be the lick
and not even it could be the lick that
like this is designed this way
yeah and it's just some of them are yeah
mind-blowing okay
i'm here for it i'm here so first one
i've got is about rick and morty okay
i've seen recommend like five times yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so rick and morty one yeah predis so
obviously you've seen ricker moy
so you notice that sometimes rick will
break the fourth wall
in terms of address the audience
directly
yes so obviously
that's to show that he knows he's on a
tv show
okay so this is because of the you know
they've got their inter-dimensional
cable episodes yes where he's he see
basically when he's watching
interdimensional cable he's just
watching other people live their lives
yes and they're all in different
universes
and their lives are his tv show yeah
so he realizes there's a dimension out
there that he's on a tv show
that's dope i like it is yeah then it
makes you think
is this a tv show it is
this is a tv show this is a tv show
of us making a tv show of someone else
watching the tv show
of someone watching someone watch us
[ __ ] yeah that's that's just blowing my
mind a little bit
which would mean potentially if the
multiverse theory is correct yeah
there's us in here yeah who are making a
show where someone would watch
uh someone yeah someone would watch us
yeah making a show yeah
someone would watch someone watching us
making a show yeah
someone would watch someone who's
watching someone who's watching us
making a show and on and on and on and
on and they're just sitting there
that's their youtube is watching someone
watching something watching something
google box times a million wow
that is it potentially is true
do you know what i mean because we don't
know if the multiverse thing is correct
if there's infinite dimensions out there
yeah then yeah it has to be
it's like it's true
i like that if there's infinity yeah
because there is because there is
it can't be the only one you can't yeah
yeah then that would be the case
oh mad that's true right that is very
trippy
that is very true because i had
obviously i've i've seen rick
rick and morty loads of times and i've
never really questioned why he talks to
the camera
yeah yeah i just thought he did it
because he's the star of the show do you
know what i mean like yeah yeah yeah
yeah just for a bit of fun yeah he knows
he's on a tv show
but because they never i don't think he
ever talks to the camera on the episodes
where they do the interdimensional
tv shows does it always different i
could just be random when he does the
wobble up a dub dub
and then he talks to the camera like
that's when you think wobble over dub
dub or he'll always be
end of season four yeah yeah yeah
so when he does the end of season four
stuff and when he breaks the fourth wall
he's not even talking to us
he's talking to whoever's in the
different dimension looking at him which
could be
us or could be anyone else or could be
the person that's watching us watching
rick and morty
that's mad yeah that is right it's mad
it is mad
stuff like that's crazy that is very mad
i like that yeah man
cool i'm here for this segment that's
what makes you think
um okay cool so we're also going to do
more would you rather's guys
so obviously if you're on the instagram
uh or on the twitter or whatever you
would have noticed that we posted the
other day just getting some more would
you rathers
so all of the red ruffles for probably
the next
10 weeks or so are all fan submitted so
if you don't like them
it's your own fault very true there's
our own fault
right so and then what we're going to do
guys we're going to spice it up a little
bit obviously you know
we have to keep it a certain level of pg
here on the um
youtube the youtube and the spotify and
stuff like that
um and we're gonna do a slightly more
heinous would you rather we're gonna
call it pick your poison
so pick your poisons over on patreon and
it's basically would you rather on
steroids
it basically is that yeah man basically
is that so um jump on and enjoy those
but
today's would you rather is this one's
actually interesting
hit me would you rather
know when you're gonna die or how you're
gonna die i think i've been asked this
one before that's
this is a popular would you rather it is
um
i would i think off the cuff
my initial response would be when purely
because if i
if i picked how i'm gonna die i'll be
forcing myself to avoid
doing this thing do you know oh yeah and
i feel like
even if i'm inevitably gonna die this
way i won't be living my life i'll be
sheltering myself from doing anything
else just
let's say for example i'm going to die
by a brick falling on my head
i don't know when that's going to
[ __ ] oh that's specific yeah that's a
terrifying one
terrifying yeah yeah yeah yeah imagine
like i'm going to die by a brick fall on
my head
i'm always going to be looking up every
everywhere i've gotten everywhere
you'll be there just to the australian
at work now do you know what i mean i
couldn't live like that
so i'd rather know when yeah just so i
know it's coming so far
but i won't know how you know yeah
imagine that day
imagine the day before the day before
you're not sleeping for days
i know it's a lose-lose it's a lose-lose
question but i'd probably
probably chew it yeah yeah probably oh
yeah the day
the day of uh i'd scream i've been like
why
what have i done i'm only 42 fam oh no
what do you mean today no
my wife's due date is next week i'm
gonna miss it all
no no double
are you answered then i'll double up um
it depends because it's like
i really really really really didn't
want to want to know when you wouldn't
want to know where would not want to
know when okay i really would not want
to know when would i
um so initially i'd be like i'd rather
know how
because i can just avoid it
and in my head i'm comfortable do you
know what i mean
so for example like if someone said oh
you're gonna die by
getting hit by a bus i know if i ever
see a bus
i'm shook but like if i'm
three streets away from a bus i know
today in the day
do you know what i mean or if there's a
bus going this way i can just prepare
myself and polite
and today but it only
turns extreme if it goes to your point
of
you're going to die by a brick on your
head or you're going to die
by a stranger stabbing you in the street
something that i can't
really control control yeah then i'm
shook yeah so
yeah it all depends because like if it's
just like you're gonna die of cancer
then i might be like that's natural of
that's fine yeah that's cool
all right cool i don't know all right
let's just bring on the cancer
and just deal with it when it comes but
yeah if it's something heinous
that you're gonna die with a brick on
your head or someone's gonna stop you in
the street and stab you
i won't be able to live my life you
remember you won't leave your yard yeah
so it's a tough one because i don't know
how likely or unlikely that is
whereas yeah fam the when
i i wouldn't the year before i i
wouldn't be able to handle it
i literally i wouldn't be able to handle
it
fam i will be breaking down i'll be
going through all the stages of grief
i'll blame everyone i blame everyone
why me any time someone complains about
anything oh my big man at least you get
to live i've got 47 days left
your mom shut up at least you get to
live
i feel so sorry for myself literally for
like three years before
same they'll it will be weird because
i think there'll probably be days where
i forget about it and then when i
remember
it all comes over me again i'm like oh
100 oh my god
fam 100 oh my god countdown i'm dying
four years ago four days
you'll be banging your wife you know the
missionary lips banging your lips and
she says i love you and you just cry
cry this ain't gonna last i love you too
i love you why is this happening to me
all right the double down was so you
said you'll pick how
you're going to die i'll pick how i said
i'll pick when yeah
double down is if you find out would you
tell anyone
if i find out how if you found out how
you're going to die would you say to
someone
i know how i'm gonna die and it's xyz
would you tell someone or would you keep
it to yourself
oh good question
i'd probably i'd have to tell someone
but have to tell yeah i'd have to tell
someone who's not like i tell someone
like you
that would deal with it but at least
you're not going to be in my ear every
day like big man what do you mean you're
going swimming
are you [ __ ] stupid
yeah if i told my wife yeah she'd just
be like you're not going anywhere yeah
you're not going you're not going to
shop are you thick
you're not leaving the yard you don't
know you can get burnt at the stake on
the way to the shop
you don't know that oh yeah i'm not
gonna have someone i'm gonna tell my
wife
i'm gonna tell my mom i'm not gonna tell
anyone who's gonna be in and trying to
stop me living my life yeah i'll tell
you
you don't give a [ __ ] about me shut the
hell up
what about you would you tell anyone um
i think i'd have to i think it
i wouldn't be able to keep something
like that to myself i
couldn't that's too juicy
that gossip is cheesy
my life is gossip you know that no i'd
have to tell i'd have to again same like
you like i wouldn't be able to tell
someone
that would kind of interfere in my life
like that yeah yeah yeah so probably
someone like you or someone like
i don't know yeah i'd have to tell
someone yeah someone because i couldn't
keep that to myself
i couldn't keep it i couldn't keep it to
myself boy but that's too much
i imagine i told you big man i know when
i'm gonna die and it's four years and
three days from now
touch wood it's not gonna happen but
yeah ah fam
you wouldn't want to see my reaction
what the [ __ ]
you'd have to explain everything to me
in molecular detail i don't know
i'll be knackered by the end of it i
might get to the point
i would say tell me everything and in
two hours later
what are we talking about we've got two
years left
hurry up um yeah if i'm i don't know
i'll be
gobsmacked i'll be gobsmacked
four years we need to boogie
we need to boogie fam in in this day and
time as well i won't know what to do
would you take risks i think i'll take
so if you say for example like you knew
like a uh a sheet like a like a
shinigami
shinigami comes down there rio comes
down and just and says
big man this is the day you know yeah
would you take risks like
i want to test if it's actually true
that kind of risk okay so like try and
kill myself beforehand yeah
obviously not try and keep shooting like
yeah actually think
let's [ __ ] see um
yes probably yes to an extent i would
probably do stuff like
because i don't want to [ __ ] like
bungee jumping skydive but obviously you
wanna skydive for your birthday
so i would probably have a lot less fear
doing stuff like yeah yeah
yeah so i feel like that would give me a
lot more
calm and ease yeah um but in terms of
actually trying to do
crazy [ __ ] maybe i don't know i don't
think maybe not
probably maybe not because i wouldn't
want to test my fate
yeah because even though it could be
this is the day you're gonna die
there's no there's no rules and
regulations saying i can't i might die
before that you know what i mean
if you're stupid if you're naked yeah
yeah yeah you could still 86 yourself
before yeah
no i'm not but this is your last chance
this is this is literally it doesn't go
past here
yeah yeah that makes sense that makes
sense i would rather i'll do a lot more
death-defying stuff yeah i'll be i'd
probably take it too far
i'll be in denial i mean denial i
believe no one's controlling my life
like that i hate authority yeah
i hate authority zeus man says you got
four years and 56 days i
bet you reckon you think so you reckon
it's like hi
g you'll find me in a red light district
no johnny's
oh wither away we'll see we will see
okay question question let's say
let's say you picked when you're gonna
die as opposed to how you're gonna die
and they say for example you're gonna
die on september the 20th
2020 2020. september 20th 2025
yeah so that's four years from now um um
the day before obviously you're
absolutely [ __ ] breaks and
at this point you've told a couple
people because you need to prepare them
yeah it's unexpected
obviously me you've told your misses
you've told your parents you thought
everyone yeah
um the day finally comes you mentally
prepare yourself you're crying you're
balling you're hugging everyone
everyone's come to say the last goodbyes
rare tear it's it's a [ __ ] sad day
bro
you sleep and you wake up the next day
what do you do
i'm supposed to be dead you're supposed
to be dead and you wake up on the 26th
so was i supposed to die on the
you're supposed to down to 25. i wake up
on 26. you wake up on the 25th
and you're alive fam oh
oh good question
i don't know i will stay in my bed for
hours
because i'll be scared to move my head
jeremy
just in case i'll be lying like this one
time
just in case i'm like
i know exactly what you're doing i'll be
sure
i don't want to sneeze i don't want to
fart or what night's happening ah
that would be horrible i'd be like if
let's say i got my mrs next to me
babe babe babe are you awake babe
babe please tell me you're there because
i'm not supposed to be alive right now
i'll be
paranoid i'll probably be more paranoid
knowing that i'm alive oh same
because it's all borrowed time now
they're playing games with me
the shinigami is playing games i'll let
them say do it
do it if you're going to do it i'm ready
you probably
ready do it i'll be crying
i'll be crying i don't think you get it
i'll be balling like what do you mean
what's going on i would laugh if i
wasn't
and you're there just crying i would
laugh at him
i would laugh oh my god oh my goodness
that's too funny that is jokes jesus
christ it's a very basic would you
rather if we got into detail i liked it
that was nice g um thank you for that
cool right i've got one um
submission from a don don yes sir
let me get my breath back that was funny
all right cool i liked this one i've
read it already
and i liked this one okay this is a
little bit of a like a sentimental one
okay um so man i like it boys
i got a little something something for
you i want to know what you think of it
somebody said so i came into uni with a
girlfriend
and always thought i was a relationship
kind of guy when we broke up i dated a
few girls
but just ended up getting hurt because
nobody wanted a relationship while
they're at uni okay
so i decided to switch it up and try the
whole life thinking it would be easy
i said fam i don't know how you guys did
it
at first i could um i said at first i
could even get a few things
to oh i couldn't i think he said
couldn't i thought at first i couldn't
even get a few things to chat to
but eventually i started chatting to a
few girls talking all the crud
and being about it i tried to play the
game but ended up catching feelings for
one of them
and ended up back at square [ __ ] one
one of the girls even told me she knew i
was new to this
and called me out as a rookie ah
my boy they didn't have to do that to my
boyfriend you didn't have to do that to
my boy
that's not cool that's not cool would be
interesting to know what your guy's view
is on being an arrest ship or a fuckboy
kind of guy
and whether you think some man just
aren't suited um
or some man i just suit you to one side
or whether you can mix and match
hmm i think off the back
anyone can mix and match i think it
depends on the
stage of life you're at and also i feel
like it also depends on your age as well
i think that's the key factor in my
opinion um
he said he he went to he's at uni right
that's what he said he either was or
he is now yeah he is now okay so he went
into
he went in with a gal and then blocked
off and he wants to try the whole life
and he got told that he's a [ __ ]
novice in the game yeah you're not built
for this that's what i said you're not
built for this
it's i feel like things like that
toughen you up
in my opinion like that's not that's
never happened to me no one's ever said
that to me before but i feel like
that would be a huge learning curve for
you because once you've
once that's happened to you in in like
you said i think you said in the other
episode where
once you're made out to be a [ __ ] kind
of thing you're gonna fix up you have to
you've got no choice now i've got
nothing left you've got no you've got
nothing left you've got no choice
i've got no pockets she took everything
he's one of them once do you know what i
mean what about your pockets
you took everything yeah yeah yeah i'm
so sorry minor
so it's one of them ones where it's
gonna either
make or break you yeah and if it breaks
you and you fall back into the
i'm just gonna be in a relationship
because it suits me kind of life yes
fair enough then
fair enough that's your comfortable spot
but then it's not really gonna
necessarily shape you as a person in my
opinion purely because
i feel like you need to live different
aspects of your life you need to branch
out and
understand who you really are as a
person
so yes that my initial answer is yes you
you can mix and match and you shouldn't
mix and match in terms of yes being a
relationship
or not necessarily being a [ __ ] boy or
fat girl um if it's a female as well
but just live your life and be free and
be single and not hold any ties or
boundaries to anyone because
life is for living life is literally for
living life is for life
you shouldn't hold yourself back to
anything or anyone and shouldn't
you shouldn't act or react um a certain
type of way because you're worried about
what other people think about you
you should just do you because at the
end of the day like you said in would
you rather you're gonna die man
big man you're gonna die someday and if
you're on a deathbed thinking i wish i
did this
and i wish i did that then you've not
really lived your life have you do you
know me yeah it's one of them ones it's
like a lot of the time
in terms of like you have to get
comfortable getting uncomfortable
very true and you it's
it's easy to think to tell yourself
because everyone
no one likes to just be uncomfortable
all the time you need to justify why you
feel a certain way
so when you're in in an uncomfortable
situation
and you've got situations like well
girls are like you know you're new to
this isn't it you're not built for this
you're not built for these streets it's
easy for you to just be like yeah you
know what maybe i'm just more of a
relationship guy
because i'm not having fun right now
yeah this whole life i'm not really
having fun right now
maybe i'm just more of a relationship
guy sometimes it's just like
maybe you are but maybe you just haven't
dived in deep enough to the point where
you're comfortable now in this new thing
because it's just like before beside the
pod you weren't a podcast guy
you said it to my face yeah yeah you
said you said what encounter
on front camera that's not me i'm just
not that kind of guy yeah yeah that's
what you said and now you
now you are yeah and it's just you have
to get uncomfortable you have to get
comfortable being uncomfortable yeah
um but at the same time that's not to
say that you're not a relationship guy
but you should always like you've said
you've tried the other side
it wasn't necessarily for you at the
time but it's just
i think it's it's just about tweaking
your perspective on it
tweaking your perspective is it's tough
to just be like you know what i'm gonna
bend my knee to the game
and i'm just gonna be in these streets
that's a very
intense mindset yeah and you're just
going to be out here
and then you think because you caught
feelings for one girl
you've lost yeah joe i mean like you you
dedicate your life to the streets and
then when you
you you divert from the code you've lost
it's just like that's
that's always going to happen yeah but
if you pattern a pen painting who's
funny
it doesn't matter if you've bent your
knee to the game you're you're
you're you're happy you're you're you're
you're you're sawing yeah
and that just happens and we fumble and
we pick ourselves up and we go again we
go back he coach puts us back
in and we move again pass us on the
shoulder sorry g come on pick yourself
up dust yourself off
we've been there bro we've always got
caught up i've been lost in the streets
a
couple
times so i found myself too deep in the
streets and places i didn't want to be
and i found myself fumbling for yes that
i thought wanted me back
yeah it happens it's life g but then you
find out you find your feet and you find
like meaningful relationships from being
in the streets
yeah and vice versa you find street life
is better for you because you're in a
[ __ ] relationship 100
so it's just a case of like sometimes
how do i explain it some people prepare
for greatness and some people have
greatness thrust upon
them you can experience that like i've
had i've had
my best time in the streets off the back
of negative situations of being in
relationships
where i'm just like you know what the
last three girlfriends i've had have
been [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm actually not happy when i'm in a
relationship yeah let me lose myself in
these streets yeah that's when
the streets come to you the streets came
to me yeah and i just got lost i was
swimming in it
i was swimming in it yes the streets
swept me up and i was just floating in
the current
that was that was that was fine as soon
as you said that i closed my eyes and
imagine
you know when you know like um uh when a
musician dives into a crowd
and they're just picking they're just
surfing and they're cross-surfing yeah
i'm just looking that's you in the
street yeah that was me in the street
jokes and then you find meaningful
relationships out there because you'd
like let me just
go in here and then like you said you
catch feedings and then she catches
feelings and you find yourself just
just tired we're just here we're here
fam this is us now and that was from
being in the streets that's
from embracing the streets exactly but
yeah
if you if you um if you if you think ah
i'm gonna do it because you should do it
but i don't really want to be here
you're not gonna have fun you're not
gonna have fun at all faster he's tip
you're tiptoeing in the streets right
now
yeah if you're if you're gonna test it
you have to yeah balls deep after balls
you have to be in the deep end
tea bag the streets bro man they'll
they'll go they'll pay you they're
paying
yeah yeah yeah man i feel like obviously
because you said um this uni time thing
so i'm assuming you're pretty young
um you're probably in the street you'll
probably be in the streets more times
than you think you've got a long life to
live maiji
yeah so yes you've experienced it now
and you say it's not really been for you
when you feel like you've
fumbled the streets because you've
caught phoenix for another thing whilst
you're in the streets big man this is
going to happen
two three four five rocky stages this is
the early stages this is literally the
warm-up
you've still got 90 minutes to play this
yeah yeah yeah you're going to go
through this stage
and then you're going to have things
that are catching videos for you that
you don't give a [ __ ] about exactly
and then you're just gonna be in like a
nice neutral ground for a while and you
think this is it
and then you're gonna fall in love again
and then someone's gonna fall and love
you it's it's a it's a mix and
make something but it's just um this is
what life is
yeah so don't feel bad don't feel like
oh i'm a relationship kind of guy or i'm
not really the streets kind of guy
and take what she said about uh you're
not you're really new to the streets
kind of thing take that and just run
with it
yeah take it as a positive and swing it
man my girl said you're a rookie you're
a
rookie
in the streets what happened for her to
say this i know what went wrong yeah
that's what we need to know that's why
you should have put it in as well i want
to know
what went wrong that's what could have
possibly gone wrong
for her to say you're new to this big
boy
you want my what my number
may ah i don't know maybe maybe
i wanted to sleep over a slightly i was
thinking he smashed
i bought a toothbrush he smashed wanted
to sleep over
a kid big man what do you think this is
it get out
get out when you [ __ ] and go what are
you doing we both died we're done
it's done what what it was aching and
back
what what is this what women want in
when you realize how savage women can be
it's
terrifying it's actually terrifying it's
absolutely terrifying i've had times
before where like
i've slept with a girl regardless of
what one i stand or whatever and then
i'm just there afterwards and i'm just
saying
so what like how was your day and she
was like what
big man i'm not it's two in the morning
get out uh well i'm not happy it's got
to say
talk to me tomorrow go just go ahead
it's peak i feel like i just need my
purse and just
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yes sometimes it can be scary when you
feel like you're getting bitched out of
a situation that's enough to make me
feel like brother fitness you shouldn't
for me
that's your first experience is it fam
ah
that's a lot that's a lot it's a lot to
swallow yeah you're like [ __ ] hell
man
is this what it is i'm just meat to
these lot they didn't even want to talk
to man
some man enjoy that some man are just
like whoa oh yes too much yeah it's too
much
early days it's too much when you're
when you're about six months in and that
happens you're gassed
gas you're thinking use me you use me
i'm here i'm
tired of these excuses use me this is
what i came from i just want a nut and
dip fandom and if you're on that vibe as
well
spud me yeah family because this is life
if that was your first rodeo
oh my god that will cut you oh fam
especially coming off
a failed relationship you have to go
home to the homies
i thought you took it off yeah my
monkeys washed by brush bags
everything towel and man's back already
walk one
foul she's not in she's not me and she's
nice and we beat and she just told me
to leave because nah that was
that was that time when this is actually
when i was early in the game actually
okay do you remember the time where um i
was
smashing you know who it is smashing she
knighted
just stop man
you need to give me more ting
banging back in uni
went to hers smashed
during the act she got hers
put a hand on my chest she didn't even
say stop she just
had on my chest ah
[Applause]
is that it they're literally out here
for themselves if they're in the streets
out there
she's got the clarity no i'm just like
why
she's thinking why would i wait for you
to fish i'm done i'm literally done
go that is that is literally posting
that clarity that's when i felt
what my mom was saying i was thinking
jesus christ the streets are tough
fam fast is this what it's about i'm not
enough to finish she
was banging she was
she was back she was banging she was
banging she was playing she was banging
her again did you oh you [ __ ] up one
no she um hollered me again
after that uh which i wish i reacted to
i told you she holded me again after but
we're on our way to the gym
and i've had my pre-workout and
everything yeah i ain't skipping this
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah monday chest day yeah
yeah i remember i went
back then i went skipping that for
nothing yeah i remember
pre-workout set in feeling good future
fitness coventry nah fam
golden era that was a good gym that was
a great gym
top three wow that was a great job it
was a sick gym but i said yeah i went
missing that for nothing
and then she we i don't think we spoke
again after that
after i didn't come through that time
she definitely got next man around damn
definitely she's a specimen
specimen indeed but yeah man um
hopefully that helped you
broski yeah sorry man it's just one of
them it is one of them you'll bounce
back you'll bounce back and if like i
said like
you're young so even if you think you
are a relationship guy
if you want to have another relationship
bro go for it just don't
i think the best thing in life is don't
search it's such a corny saying
in terms of like oh you can't love
anyone until you learn to love yourself
but i am a firm believer
of spending a lot of time by yourself is
the most
therapeutic thing without a shadow of a
dog when you ain't hunting for a
girlfriend
or you're not desperately trying to
avoid a girlfriend and you're just in
that middle ground
and you're just doing what you do just
wake up every day focus on yourself
just do [ __ ] learn more about yourself
and just do [ __ ] that you like to do
yeah
fam oh it's it's it's a good therapy
yeah
so that's when you find the ting either
the perfect
[ __ ] buddy or whatever or the perfect
misses or anything they just line up
that when you're
when your eye is off the game you just
you're in the streets but you're just
walking from you're just passing through
you're passing through and everyone's
just staring at it yeah you don't lift
it
you're just passing through they're
thinking this guy what's he doing what's
he doing here that's what he wants
exactly he's here for him damn yeah man
that's when you have the best time
you'll learn that soon enough g
um it's not necessarily as good that you
took this l
um so soon in the game but
there's no you won't get a worse l than
this i don't think because this will
like i said this will
this will develop you yeah this will
make you stronger so like like
um what's his name big sean said last
night i took it l but tonight i bounce
back g you have to bounce back
you're gonna have a choice you've got no
choice you have to bounce back yeah you
can't let the game crumble you can't
there's no favorites in the game there
aren't you have to bounce back please
please for us man please check in in a
couple months
drop us a message and just say fellas
thank you thank you i bounced back
car these men were trying to rob me
blind
i was struggling i'm not gonna lie i was
hungry
day two everything with the purse
it happens and it will happen more than
once g so it's just life this is life
but yeah it is it is um
just before we wrap up yeah i've got um
the i don't think i can do crime dramas
anymore
or crime docs anymore i love crime
documentaries oh i know
i love crime documents fam i know
i've watched a few the last there's um
one
guy one um fan messaged me the other day
about one i was gonna watch
okay anyway i need to watch it it's
about the um what's it called it's
called like scene of the crime or
something like that
on netflix i've seen the cecil hotel
i've seen the trailer but i've not seen
it i want to watch it i've seen the
trailer
i've seen it i've seen the trailer i
already know the story about there's a
lot more in the dock that i don't know
about but like i know the main crux i
can tell you this is this is before i
found this information out
about this hotel before this documentary
was ever made um
but basically there's a hotel in l.a
called the cesar hotel
there's a there's a this is in the
documentary there's a woman
who they got her on camera yeah in the
elevator
shook shook and she's just like looking
out the tip you can't see anyone but the
doors won't close
the doors will not close fam and she
keeps peeking out like that
and she shook fam and then i think that
eventually the door's closed she's there
fam so she's gone she goes missing
she goes missing no one can find her fam
i don't know how long it was it may be a
few days or a few weeks because i don't
know that much about the story but i
know they found her
um in the water tank
the water tank to the hotel they found
her in because
the people in the hotel was drinking the
water
and they were like it's
is a bit tangy there's a satin gun in
the water it smells a bit and it's a bit
tangy
so the plumbers was like all right so
they they couldn't figure out so they
had to check the water tank
fam they
you can't open this water tank
you can't open it without heavy
machinery to get in there
it's sealed off the whole thing's sealed
off
you can't get in oh and they found her
corpse in there
oh my it's a complete and utter mystery
no one knows how she got in there
all they know is that she was shook in
the thing
and then a few days later a couple of
men and she's floating in the thing that
no one could you had
you had to bust the thing open no way
and the police said and everyone said
fam
there's no there's no way possible a
human being could open that
and seal it back up it's impossible no
one could have opened that
chucked her in there and sealed it back
up it's impossible can't be done
paranormal in it paranormal
paranormal and they when you dig into
the history of the hotel
it turns out loads of creepy people
happened to just to lodge at this hotel
like loads of weird [ __ ] is connected to
the doctor have you seen the night
stalker
on netflix as well no i don't think so
oh my god fam i watched it the other day
i've seen i think i've seen this it's
like a three-four partner i think i've
seen the trailer oh my god it's about a
don
who um in la in the 70s 80s
i've definitely seen this trailer um
we're just killing people
but he got away with it for so long
because
he there was no rhyme or reason to he
there was no patterns
he would just kill people and when i say
fam
he would do he is the first person in
criminal history who would do the whole
shebang
he would he was a murderer he was a
rapist
and he was a pedophile oh wow
fam serial rapist serial murderer cyril
pedro oh wow
he would just pick and do it so if he
was just roaming around la
and killing people he saw he went into a
um uh account i try not to support the
whole thing but there's so much i can't
spoil the whole thing yeah yeah yeah
he walked he walks into a [ __ ] cafe
sees one yeah
um and she sees like a
a cap so he was in there he left and he
left his cap on the table okay and she's
cleaning the table she sees it's an ac
dc cap she picks it up she's just oh
okay
and then my man walks in doesn't say
nothing and he's got [ __ ] up teeth
he's got like meth head teeth
[ __ ] up teeth and she he walks in
there doesn't say nothing stares at her
and just takes the hat
and puts it on and smiles at her she's
like cool
fam he walks out her shift ends she
drives home
this is la by the way big [ __ ] city
she's driving home
as she's driving fam one car zooms past
her
slows down just so they meet eye level
she looks
fam my man's staring at her smiling ac
dc hat
side by side fam ha ha i would peel
the [ __ ] off fam or peel off she was
[ __ ] terrified she's thinking what
the
nowhere in her head she's thinking he
stayed and waited for me yeah she's
thinking what are the [ __ ] odds
this is the same don she's not thinking
he's followed me big man
she drives home um
actually no no that's it he peels off
okay so they make eye contact he smiles
he peels off
she gets home my man's car's at her yard
fam
we don't know how we don't know how
how does he know these things he could
have been following her for days he must
have been in the in the shadows
um she gets home blood all his car's
there
the garage is open blood everywhere
blood everywhere so
she's not nighttime this is at night
time okay so
she um what happened
she walks in to a yard
her housemate's dead did she see the
blood before she walked in yeah
she saw the blood on the on the concrete
open open the thing
my man comes out no no no no
what is it i don't think she did go in i
don't think sorry i'm messing it up she
pulls up
sees my man's car blood on the floor
she's like what the [ __ ]
as she's got out of her car
my man's come out of the yard of the
yard
from my hands are here she says stop
man's pointing the gun at her she's like
bang shoots her drops her
he goes back in the yard
to finish off to finish off whatever the
[ __ ] he was doing in there
turns out she had her keys in her hand
so when she's here the bullet had
ricocheted off the keys
luckiest thing of all time luckiest
thing of all time
she darts round the back of the house
thinking
she hears a gunshot so mama's finished
to do finish what he's going to do
she hears a gunshot she darts back round
the back of the house instead of [ __ ]
off
she does round the back of the house
thinking he's going to come out the back
of the garage so she runs around to the
front door
as she gets to the front door my man
comes out the [ __ ]
front door he isn't running anywhere fam
he's here he walks out the front door
bumps into her again thinking ra
killed you fam she says
please you already shot me once don't
shoot me again
man says calm walks off
doesn't run doesn't attack her doesn't
hide his face
walks off he doesn't give a [ __ ]
i would live in fear for the rest of my
life oh fam ellie was locked down
no one was leaving yours because he was
doing this for weeks months
just picking people fam looked inside he
was just walking past a yard
looked and saw like a child's bedroom
looked inside
the bedroom so a little girl sitting
there six-year-old girl she took her
climbed in the bedroom window picked her
up she's waking up and he was um
a latino guy and she was a latina girl
so he worked she was like so delirious
bless her little six-year-old so
delirious that she looked up
saw a latino guy and assumed it was an
uncle or something
took her out the window only once she
got in the car and she's driving down
the road is she thinking
what the [ __ ] yeah where am i
she's scared now if i'm six six
takes her to this dodgy area
um and takes the dodgy area
and literally says do not say a [ __ ]
word takes her in the yard
melissa for like three days six
then gets her back in the car drives her
to
a bus stop or some [ __ ] and just lets
her out
he's like cool i need to watch this
didn't kill her
fam i need to watch this that's his
patterns didn't make sense he's killing
some people
letting some people live shooting them
not shooting him again
raping little girls dropping him back
home he rapes
90 year old women he kills husbands and
wives he kills
any one fam he just bustes in your yard
in the middle of the night and kills you
he doesn't give a single [ __ ] oh my god
the whole thing is mad and sorry to tie
it all up the whole time he was doing it
he was staying at the cecil hotel
apparently he used to rock up there arse
naked and because his hotel's so [ __ ]
people wouldn't even pay attention that
he'd come there asked naked he'd [ __ ]
kill someone
take all his gums off put him in a
random trash can i'll burn him and just
go back to the hotel naked
and they were like [ __ ] hit josh
again
naked josh and then blood you're right
and he's like you're right
and then just go and they think he's
just a [ __ ] crazy guy who comes here
naked
this is the cecil hotel like [ __ ]
happens
damn fam nuts
but when i saw that i was thinking thank
god i live in an apartment
thank god i live in an apartment because
i couldn't handle that that's not
happening
i could not handle that if i was in a
yard watching that in the middle of the
night
and i'm supposed to just go to bed nah
fun i'm looking i've been shaking at
night if i heard a little ch
nah nah nah nah sorry no
it's long that's that's terrifying
that's terrifying it's mad
but the way they the way they caught him
was was decent like the clues and stuff
that i'm not gonna spoil it the clues i
had to put together
these detectives went through it but
through it
and it actually gives you do you know
when you have situations where like
uh police will give out certain
information
or people are trying to help with the
case and police have to say you should
stop stop [ __ ]
doing anything yeah and people like
what's the [ __ ] problem we're just
trying to help
this is the documentary really leads
into examples of where
people have tried to do stuff and [ __ ]
everything up
and then the police have to start again
from scratch when they were like this
close to catching him
mad mad
it's good um but yeah anyway guys watch
the nightstalker
watch scene of the crime i think that's
what it's called on netflix um i'm gonna
watch it
starting probably tonight and thank you
for tuning in this week we love you
um as per usual like comment subscribe
leave a review leave a comment
jump on the patreon on the patreon and
uh have a good week